I'm a trainee in the press office the  main tasks there include monitoring  social media attending meetings and  drafting reports background briefings  press releases and other products for  the press working in the press office of  the council has been a great experience  for me  you practically work as a press officer  and when there is a European Council the  Chinese are asked to help out a press  team we report on national press  conferences and keep an eye on what is  happening on social media right before  during and after the meeting I have  learned to filter information quickly to  draft different types of documents and  to use social media in a professional  context so yeah it has been a great  experience  you